لم يكن لدي أي طاقة فقط
أردت فقط أن أترك وحدي
، خشب جنيف البالغ من العمر تسع سنوات ، كنت متأكدًا من أنها
كانت تأخذ أنفاسها الأخيرة.
اتصل أطباء عائلتي بعائلتها ليقولوا
وداعهم الأخير كانت
رئتيها تمتلئان بالسوائل وكانت مستويات الأكسجين
في كل مكان متقلبة
ولم يعتقدوا أنها
ستجعلها قد نجت للتو من سكتة دماغية ولكن
لإعادة التأهيل  تم إرسالها إلى دار لرعاية المسنين
لم أستطع التحدث ولم أستطع المشي ولم أستطع
فعل أي شيء لنفسي وفجأة
كانت تموت ليس من سكتة دماغية ولكن من
تعاقدها في الساعة 19:00 هناك
اتضح أن دار رعاية وودز كانت الأولى
مكان في أمريكا لتفشي فيروس كورونا الجديد المميت بشكل كبير والذي
يعود من سكتة دماغية
إلى الجدة القوية المشاكسة الإرادة
التي نجت
من العشرات من الكساد والإنفلونزا والحرب
العالمية الثانية كانت مجرد صدفة
لها ثم جسدها البالغ من العمر 90 عامًا  قاتل مرة أخرى
كان ب  قادرًا على أن أكون مع أطفالي ،
أعطه تشاك عناقًا أو ركلة أو أي شيء
يحتاجون إليه ، اعتقدت أنك
ستقول عناقًا أو قبلة ، لكنك خدعتني
وكان ذلك مضحكًا للغاية ، لقد عادت
ترفس بأعقابها وهي تستمتع بكرسيها المفضل
وتصنعها  حساء البطاطس
الخاص بها ولا
تجازف واستمر في محاربة سارة سيدنر سي إن إن